au kenya
[Musique]
oh
ok
[Musique]
oui car à peine regarder voler je vais
les écarts
on attend
là
m
moi je suis content de revenir ici
oui oui si ça m'a dit eh bien moi c'est
julie bon c'est un peu de mal je lui dis
je un coup de main c'est pourquoi ma vie
bah c'est à dire que c'est comme la
dernière
oui c'est à la victime en la dernière de
la saison
c'est pour ça qu'on va mettre une
ambiance de dingue j'arrive pas tu
comprends je suis arrivé je suis
enthousiaste avant de rentrer je sais
pas je ne sais pas ce qu'on entend c'est
comme si j'avais des amis tu vois qui
est hyper pointu m'a dit merci la
dernière c'est vrai qu'à tes sales et le
mariage des têtes kuchar verrez jamais
tellement certain ça fait du bien de
palerme et donc on attend
si tu veux on peut faire un petit
sondage qu'il est prêt à vendre papilles
pour les grandes vacances
du 20 au 28 juillet lever la main
voilà au pool mois d'août chez que c'est
un peu plus compliqué qui peut pas pis
pour le mois d'août
ah oui layan d'un qui est forcé à les
forcer voilà les gens forcés ou les
forces d'avenir
bon écoute et on va pas plomber
l'ambiance de ce soir c'est la fête
super non mais ça fait plaisir quand
même au fond oui au fond il ya un truc
tu dis il s'est passé quelque chose dans
cette ville wikitrust passé peut-être
pas grand chose mais maintenant il se
passait on a appris plein de choses on a
on a appris qu'ils avaient un marché non
repas à maurepas
mais là on est à il encourt donc
commencé par faire des conneries parce
que si tu veux qu'on revienne l'année
prochaine oui j'avais l'espoir encore là
c'est foutu là tu vois qu'ils n'oublient
pas qu'ils allaient lui et la culture
qui traîne dans les parages
vidéo je ne sais pas il dit ces petites
plantes maintenant tu as vu la peur ils
se planquent c'est vrai qu'ils étaient
là au premier ou au deuxième plateau
lever la main cibler leurs commandes
c'est des amis et qui la première fois
levé la main web un témoin pas au revoir
à dieu
je veux c'est des gens j'aurais pu les
connaître j'aurais pu entrer dans leur
vie vivent des choses intenses avec eux
c'est la tenir x men on les laisse pas
abattre dans les mains alors on a réglé
ça fait peur c'est trop la fête la
tchèque jana
je peux déjà ils n'arrêtent pas de me
répéter une blague depuis tout à l'heure
alors je me suis dit élan courtoise élan
courtois alors quoi vous je sais qu'il
ya des gens qui viennent pas d'elancourt
ils sont des gens ils encourent là se
pose pas
ah quand même en fait c'est une soirée
placée sous le signe du levé la main oui
c'est très participative monde c'est
vrai qu'un les communales font peu du
fond mais avec applaudissements tout ça
nous fait pas ça
et donc alors eh oui oulaï généralement
quand shane black ça tombe à plat c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait cela cet épais
comme prévu au programme
alors j'en profite parce que comme c'est
ma dernière vas-y dépêche-toi alors oui
pardon alors élan courtoise et
l'important je dis oh oui courtois
courtoisie un élan de courtoisie voilà
je vais pas la norme il fallait il faut
des années et des années de pratique et
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait venir des
vrais humoristes fins atteint 28 juin et
non alors des vrais oui voilà
bon alors il ya enfin on fait venir des
humoristes qui sont pas finies fini les
gens qui reviennent ils le savent ils
sont là tous ils sont et d'érudits bord
de trouille nous nécessaire travail
d'alger l'impression d'être bon quand je
relis non mais tu comprends tu vas
rentrer sur scène tu rentres tu te poses
viennent au centre tué planté là tu
regardes le public tu n'oublies pas de
regarder au public et tout ce qui va se
passer c'est dans la rythmique on est
d'accord
non c'est un peu apprécié à ses fans de
l'essence et l'achète
bon écoute avis on va accueillir le
premier artiste de la soirée
il est d'ici il est du coin il est du
cru l'a vécue et louis
il fait de l'improvisation certains le
connaissent déjà
je vais vous demander de trouver un
aboutissement
aux mollahs
[Musique]
comment
mais
mais fo
sogo la famille ouais ouais
un bordel wali voiture ici ça va bien
les amis
et monter un tout coup là ça fait
plaisir car elles vont allumer qui m'ont
laissé regard monde y est inquiet talent
t'avouerai autres le pose août mais le
micro sur le tabouret géant fallu aller
chercher le tabouret apprécié été
chercher le micro est si mr pour
l'entrée papy tu méthanier pas là
l'année prochaine ça va ou quoi elle en
cours ouais
face à un public de finir ce sont
roquois je fais du bruit les frères
allez allez allez
ah ah ça fait plaisir mais c'est la
famille c'est bien faut toujours dire
c'est la famille comme ça les gens ils
se disent ah t'as vu mais qui nous
quitte déjà moi je kiffe personne
cherche et je suis d'elancourt je suis
lent courtois courtoisie que dalle
déjà le mec a trouvé le nom d'elancourt
c'était une feignasse taux courts et
longs coups ne seront ensuite les élans
courtois moi je suis sur le mec il a vu
deux élans courir il a dit ce sera l eau
recours après il a tué un des deux élans
et l'a vendu
et quand il a vendu le mec il a été
grapho c'est pas le client il a dit
merci aux mecs c'est l'huile a dit mme
mercier aux clients
et là c'était un courtois frère après la
guerre on sera les lots à lui a pas
compris mais il y en a au bout et spa il
y aurait une vidéo qui pourra en voir ma
plaque je te laisserais réfléchir je te
laisse reçu mon facebook si tu as besoin
je te ferai un détail de la plaque
non moi j'ai grandi elle en cours ou
intermarché
mais sur le intermarché sur le toit mon
père il nous avait fait une par acte
aurait vu sa magnifique
on aurait dit une villa mais sur
intermarché on était sur le parking
d'intermarché
c'était agréable y avait des pompes à
essence quand il faisait chaud l'été on
se mettait de l'essence dessus ça
rafraîchit sait
il n'y avait pas les moyens de faire une
piscine et comme le chauffage était cher
on s'en servait aussi l'hiver c'est un
concept de vie on était à côté de france
miniature et le mec à l encours qui
s'est dit on va faire la france
miniature et voici vous croyez c'est un
génie juste le mec qui l'a pas mis
elancourt dans la france miniature et ça
toute ma jeunesse on m'a rendu fou je me
suis dit le mec il habite une ville il a
une idée où on va tout faire en mini
dans un pays il a même pas mis sa petite
ville en tout petit
[Musique]
peu après j'ai quitté il encourt un jour
mon père m'a dit tu sais fixe je fais
partir du tiroir pourquoi tu pas où il
m'a dit je pars en jamaïque
je suis dit mais pourquoi je pars pour
la droite fils bon là je suis papa tu as
duclos tu veux pas partir comme ça
encore moins le tir à ton fils dis moi
je sais pas je vais voir un concert de
bob marley quelque chose alors il est
parti
les modifie ce qu'est ce que tu veux
venir avec moi j'ai dit oui mais moi je
prends pas de drogue un des enfants dans
la salle
priez des adultes qui répondent oui
on prend pas de drogue les enfants c'est
pas bien il y en a il en a pris il ya
des adultes ont des enfants dans la
salle pourquoi il ya des enfants qui
réponde à cette question
il marche sur la tête ce public vous
dire à vos enfants ne pas prendre de
drogue c'est pas dire la drogue mois à
cause de papa quand on est en jamaïque
je suis parti deux semaines survenu je
me rappelle que final que l'alcool rien
sur moi beau voyage on sait pas par moi
jamais trop raconté rentrer quand je
suis rentré il a fallu j'habitais à
trappes
ah ouais ohlala tu passes tes l'encours
à trappes
c'est pas si différent dans les justes
elles encourent village et plein de
belles maisons
tu rajoutes un épicier qui ferme à deux
heures une crêperie qui ferme à deux
heures et un capa qui ferme à 2h pas
juste en plus quoi mais c'est bien ça
évite de faire les courses
mais ça coûte cher j'ai même porté pour
le couple mais qui tient le cap ap
je lui ai dit tu fais exprès mais tu
reste ouvert quatre heures après le
franprix ce qui te permet que moi et ma
vie de feignasses on vient dépenser tout
motul c'est toi il m'a dit si vous
voulez j'ai dit bien joué très bien joué
et puis après quand survenue à trappes
le logement c'était bien mais pour payer
le logement il crée pape dans le
logement
il faut travailler j'avais la flemme
franchement j'avais pas envie du tout
mais je me suis dit il faut bien
travailler
alors au début je cherchais plutôt du
côté de paris j'allais dans les
entretiens d'embauché parler comme ça
oui bonjour qualité vont passer aux
défauts je suis assez long long mais bon
principal c'était bon
je suis le seul à être bon ici au lit
je te remercie mon pote à paris j'ai
travaillé dans un endroit avec des gens
que j'avais pu rencontrer des quais
il en faut un c'est comme tout il faut
que tout le monde soit amoureux tout le
monde c'est le principal
mais imaginez un peu le truc quand tu
rentre le soir et explique à tes potes
que ton rh
il sort avec ton pg
que l'autre vendeurs qui travaille avec
toi il était célibataire
abbas a jasé au quartier tout le monde
disait on m'a tuer les quais excusé mais
non enfin peut-être
et puis dans le fond est-ce que c'est
grave mais je me suis rendu compte que
je n'étais pas vraiment qu'est le jour
où j'ai fait ma première soirée quai âgé
était oui moi aussi j'étais très surpris
je me suis un peu fait avoir
le thème c'était orgie grecque
moi enregisté la bouffe tu vois je me
suis dit on va manger plein de kebab
opus c'est paris peut-être que le kebab
y ferme à trois ou quatre heures encore
plus arrangeant 4 ap
c'est pas du tout ce que j'ai vu qu'ils
avaient de la sauce blanche beaucoup de
sauce blanche faut pas en abuser
attention il ya des gens qui me disent
c'est beau quand la peau vous essayez de
dire ça ma première petite copine je me
suis pris une grande tarte dans la
gueule et mme habitants la ballon
excusez moi excusez moi non pardon on
m'a dit c'est un spectacle familial moi
j'aime la famille vivre la famille
du coup premier soir c'était en
amèrement mdi bras vient la soirée tu
t'habilles en grec en dieu grec
je sais pas si quelqu'un déjà vu mes
pectoraux dans la salle
il faudrait que je fasse au moins six ou
sept modes prison avant de prendre un
mec compliqué compliqué alors du coup je
suis arrivée à la soirée
je me suis dit je vais arriver un petit
peu plus tard comme ça il me
remarqueront pas
ils m'ont tout de suite vu déjà je suis
arrivé il y avait des mecs ils étaient
déguisés vraiment dû et déesses grecques
carré - y avait un mec il avait fait une
couronne sur sa tête avec des raisins
ils étaient maquillés il avait une mini
jupe qui terminer ici et un string qui
terminait là ils avaient des talons qui
arrivait à mon genou
quel mec s'est baladé à l'aise toute la
soirée et là je me suis dit respect
j'avais compris le truc moi j'avais mis
un short
pas fou le gars il ya même un moment un
mec il est venu me voir et m'a dit t'es
torontois
j'ai dit oui il est parti il est revenu
et m'a dit ce n'est pas pour moi j'étais
pour quelqu'un en plus c'était pour qui
aime à montrer un mec je lui ai dit non
non je peux pas son été avec plaisir
enfin j'en sais rien au fond
qui paraît que qui ne trouvent rien à
rien il ya des gens qu'on trouvait ici
à chacun ses délires moi je juge pas
mais je constate
mais ce qui est bien avec les gays c'est
toutes les filiales ont un meilleur pote
qui est là quand les gays font des
soirées tous les gays y ramène leur
meilleur pote copenhague leur
mère-patrie mr copé est là
la soirée commence à devenir cool parce
qu'elles sont pas gays
toi tu es le seul hétéros qui te fait
draguer par les gays les meufs en
deviennent jalouse non mais c'est tout
un concept
c'est un truc parisien je pense nous
celle où auront lieu on peut pas
comprendre le train il est trop loin ça
40 minutes pour y aller par un train
toutes les heures tu peux pas te rendre
compte de la différence trop compliqué
alors du coup cette foire et orge y
kebab raté j'ai appelé cette soirée
alors au fond de la cuisine en train de
rouler en deux roues les dents de rouler
à vélo dans la cuisine je faisais des
tours de vélo dans la cuisine et là il
ya une belle demoiselle hyper mignonne
tu voyais que c'était une fille un peu
chic du mois grosse grosse des lèvres ap
arables caraïbes où elle pouvait faire
genre du tomtom avec ses lèvres un truc
2 tu vois
elle est venue boire et un petit est
beau gosse de latérite et compris
attaquable acheter tout cela en train de
faire du vélo dans la cuisine du collège
sanji tu fais quoi
je roule à vélo je lui dis tu veux
monter sur le guidon même dit non
rentrons albert jacquard ouais mais j'ai
plus de batterie ans je te préviens tu
vas être obligé de payer le père ça n'a
pas dérangé à me dire non non le
principal c'est pas le problème c'est
toi j'ai tué c'est gentil
c'est gentil non j'étais comme un conte
j'attendais mon premier train était à
6h30
il était à peine 23h30
ah non ça c'est les planques à l'air
heureusement mademoiselle habite à
neuilly la cage d'escalier mon frère est
les boîtes aux lettres
elles étaient toutes au mur tout au
mieux il y avait personne dans la cage
d'escalier wiens avait même pas mais qui
dormait dans un duvet ou quoi que ce
soit aucune misère j'ai rien vu car on
est en escalier les marges les mêmes sur
les marches tout les mêmes les mecs ils
avaient mis un tapis rouge
tu imagines tu rentres chez toi tu sois
du travail le soir tu es là tu arrives
dans un tapis rouge dans l'escalier qui
même mec j'ai réussi ma vie c'est tout
réussi bon le père s'est planté de route
il nous a menés à bon temps au début ça
allait mais la nada battu mais qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
pourtant après du canal de l'ourcq elle
s'est mise en citer toutes les origines
possibles autour du canal de l'ourcq
je suis inquiète pas moi je suis trop
j'ai la psychologie de la banlieue j'ai
chopé le beurre juillet roue tourne à
neuilly frère il faut que je voie ce
bâtiment
du coup on se retrouve à nuit sheila
bair et vous devinerez jamais elle avait
quoi dans son appart sa vue vous n'avez
pas deviné qu'est jean et non êtes trop
naze à qui doivent asie qui l avait
kouakou co paris doucement doucement tu
atteins coquin
bien sûr que je vais me glisser dans ce
lit un chat non je suis allergique c'est
moche c'est chiant je comprends pas les
gens qui aiment les chats y en a qui
aiment les chats bon ben voilà ça
m'intéresse même pas vous voyez non
monsieur
ouais non mais franchement si j'avais un
chat ce serait pour acheter un chien
pour qu'il bouffe le champ c'est un
concept c'est un concept on peut pas
juger constater et du coup avec cette
nana non non elle n'avait pas de chat
laver à 1,10 et yves mans mais la fune
subi les semis né dans un appart
moi j'ai mon voisin est fêtée des
créatures sont pas contents en temps
mais c'est tout jamais en est qui s'est
dit je voulais faire une cheminée dans
mon appart
c'est nous disent on est heureux d'avoir
le le chauffage collectif qu'est ce tu
veux que j'aille acheter des bus de bois
sérieux enfin c'était un délire c'était
sympathique bon après il était 3 4
heures moi je lui ai dis franchement je
vais aller me coucher
elle m'a dit mais tu veux pas jouer
sinon franchement là moi je vais me
coucher
elle fait ça parce qu'il ya des gosses
mais vous savez
vous avez compris pourquoi j'ai dit si
bien merci
[Musique]
et
marcel longtemps couru ni pato
voilà c'est comme ça qu'on m'offre c'est
un bon début maclin malades
or voulait à la terre monsieur de l'âge
alors messieurs de l'âge comme ça vous
croyez que c'est la fête je faisais la
fête derrière avec les ahlaouis alors
que pardon oui bon ça fait plaisir à la
paix non ma vie reste baby pourquoi tu
t'en vas papier matures du coup c'est
quoi ton actu voilà je parle
voir mon père en jamaïque la semaine
prochaine oui après vu que la demoiselle
avait l'air d'avoir pas mal de souche
d'essayer de me marier rapidement et
sinon j'ai un poteau un vrai frère de la
streak qui fait un spectacle de ouf qui
s'appelle antoine improvise avec lui
même et c'est tous les samedis dimanches
parce que moi j'ai pas de promo je fais
celle des autres ouais d'accord c'est
bien voilà vous voyez encore la plus
dire merci à tous merci matthieu
remportent un temps couvert
bah voilà pourtant tabou mais est là
c'est la fête nous tous mis assez génial
c'est durant ce raid on peut tous nous
mêmes c'est génial j'adore c'est drôle
hein voilà
est ce qu'on s'amuse bonne soirée au si
votre dernière soirée mais non pas du
tout mais non on alors cela rires pour
cette dernière soirée
qu'est-ce que j'ai ri à cette dernière
soirée alors enfin c'est pas tout ça
mais on a quand même un plateau et là on
va accueillir quelqu'un qui vient de
loin tintin ah oui alors c'est un bol
parce que la jeune femme qui va passer
après et viennent de belgique
ouais c'est vrai et ce qui est drôle
parce que c'est trop elle m'a dit bon
comment je viens elancourt alors je lui
dis je prends le train tu vas gare du
nord tu prend la 4 tu arrives à
montparnasse tu peux en direction
rambouillet à rambouillet tu descends là
derrière tes pas arrivé parce qu'une
fois que la verrière tu prends le bus
est arrivé là il m'a dit ok c'est bon et
puis su message hier soir dit je suis en
voiture
voilà donc vous le savez c'est notre
second artiste
oui non des moindres à ou ne peut pas
arriver bientôt sur scène sa chaîne
kaoutar tôt ou tard quelqu'un de
belgique
voilà rien que pour eux ce soir pour
digérer ce soir au parc
[Musique]
café
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir paris
enfin paris j'ai cru que c'était paris
vienne bruxelles comme vous expliquez
moi j'ai vraiment cru que c'était paris
dont j'avais prévenu mon billet train
jusqu'à la gare du nord etc
j'avais pas qu'il fallait encore prendre
l'avion n'aurait pas pris mon passeport
la paperie de casse croûte
j'avais pas pris ma burqa lorsque j'ai
vu que dans le quartier avait beaucoup
de shows kotov c'est pour ça que je me
présente je m'appelle kaoutar mes amis
m'appellent chaos parce que c'est plus
court c'est plus facile à retenir et
puis ça veut dire vaches en anglais je
sais exactement ce que vous êtes en
train de vous dire mais quel lien
pourrait-il y avoir entre cette
délicieuse créature est une vache aucun
et celui qui ose pense l inverse
attention parce que tu as de molenbeek
en mémoire ne prenez pas trop de risques
alors je m'appelle kaoutar kaouther ça
veut dire abondance en arabe ces gens
comprennent arabe ici dans cette wii une
wii je suis là donc ça veut dire
abondance
effectivement j'ai la chance
d'expérimenter l'abondance chaque jour
de ma vie 1
abondance de factures abondance de
rupture abondance de courbure
non ça c'est pas grave c'est j'ai appris
à l'accepter comme dirait un grand
philosophe belle journée un seul
philosophe en belgique il était vivre
aux états unis
et tu sais le principe pas être aware
hockey j'espérais tout symptôme
incorporait sa norme cocaïnomane hommes
ce qui veut dire un esprit sain dans un
corps sain avec des petits ça tiens
c'est moi ouais parce que je sais pas si
vous voyez quand vous regardez mon corps
j'ai été livré avec un corps à gros
seins s'en laissa donc j'en profite ce
soir je sais que la presse présente donc
s'il vous plaît je transmet un message
si on retrouve mes seins j'aimerais bien
les avants nomme ça fait 25 ans que les
attend pour rigoler mais c'est assez
horrible je suis je suis d'une plate s à
l'école on m'appelle platon
c'est un truc de fou c'est dur de vivre
et que le sms le sms le syndrome des
micro st
quand c'est super dur en plus comme j'ai
pas vraiment une corpulence qui a adapté
imaginez un peu l'ascenseur émotionnel
pour les mecs que j'ai connu les pauvres
tu vois c'est un peu comme si tu vas une
grosse carrosserie ça je sais pas moi
une 4 4 puis monte à l'intérieur suite
mauvais lancer des pédales à vélo
supercherie non non c'est pas bien à
papa faire des trucs comme ça ce qui est
bien c'est qu'on radie kaoutar
t'inquiète pas le jour autant à des
enfants tant à dessein
j'en ai trois j'ai passé un marché pour
vous les filles il ya des moments dans
la salle ouais c'est un marché pour vous
oui pour toi avez chacun son terme à ces
super je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
défi quand vous êtes enceinte
il ya toujours une espèce de potiche
dans votre entourage qui a un ventre
super plein qui a pas d'enfants qui en
aura jamais cette [__] elle n'aura
jamais d'enfant elle vient vous caresser
le ventre tu as comme ça et on va les
venue elle m'a fait ouais c'est trop
mignon tu as une préférence
je lui dis ouais 95d c'est bien après ce
géant connaissez je vais pas faire ma
chiante un nom moi du moment que ils
sont en bonne santé pas de kiss pas de
fibromes bien réguliers bien faire bien
haut je m'engage à les aimer de manière
inconditionnelle
non mais écoutez ça n'a pas marché avec
trois enfants
je me suis dit peut-être que j'aurais dû
persévérer parce que quand je regarde ma
mère elle en a eu sept et chez elle ça
bien foisonner fonctionner ouais ma mère
c'est un peu l'inversé de moi moi je
suis un triangle sur base ma mère c'est
un peu le triangle sur pointes
c'est à dire quand elle se met devant
moi à nous deux en forme l'étoile de
david g j'ai jamais fait part de cette
comparaison ma mère sinon je ne serais
pas là pour vous l'expliquer non mais
c'est vrai ma mère elle a vraiment eu
sept enfants je suis la 7e elle a eu six
garçons avant moi donc en toute logique
comme elle a eu six garçons elle voulait
plus d'enfants donc voila mais bon je
suis quand même arrivé tu va déterminer
mais c'est vrai que je me suis posé la
question je suis amer a comme il cet
enfant est ce qu'elle voulait vraiment
en avoir sept combien est-ce que ma mère
voulait d'enfants que tu poser ces
questions parce que comme la vouloir la
pénitence à cet enfant il faut être
motivé donc j'étais là à voir un jour ma
mère je posais la question je dis maman
à la base tu voulais combien d'enfants
elle m'a répondu ah merde oublierai
jamais massa écoute moi bien m'a fait
mozilla des comptes tu penses non tes
doigts des roues et et moi j'ai pensé
cette fois non à l'ue et la 17e fois oui
et je voulais comme ça je faisais tous
venez cafsa castard ça veut dire la rage
quand vous étiez vraiment des
spermatozoïdes
tu vois qu'ils ont pas lâché la faire je
dis je fais je répondu maman tu es en
train de me dire qu'à aucun moment tu
n'as rien senti cet élan intérieur
intrinsèque puissant qui te pousse vers
ce désir irrépressible de devenir mère
en fait je crois pas en faire ce qu raté
plateau j'ai répondu à ta question là il
faut pas pousser bobonne dans la tour t1
donc voilà elle voulait zorro enfants
c'est à dire que mathématiquement au
premier enfant sa motivation était 2 0
et je suis la 7e je vous laisse faire un
peu de calcul
donc je suis arrivé dans ces conditions
très heureuse n'est ce pas et je pense
que c'est pour ça que m'a donné ce
prénom
kaoutar savaient pas très fille kaoutar
se termine en art comme edgar edouard
connard que des attributs typiquement
masculin on est bien d'accord et c'est
je crois que ce qui m'a donné aussi ce
côté un petit peu vous savez androgyne
mi femme mi jin
mais je tiens à rassurer l'audience de
ce soir je suis 100% hétérosexuels
célibataire souple et disponible
non mais c'est vrai c'est pas évident je
suis vraiment célibataire parce qu'à
chaque fois que j'étais avec un mec en
fait il avait toujours quelque chose à
dire si ce n'est pas le point c'était la
tenue vestimentaire
mon dernier mais qui me disait chéri
maigri pas trop les os et pour les
chiens
ai je répondu ça tombe bien parce que
d'aussi loin que je me souvienne j'ai
connu que ça les chiens non je plaisante
messieurs j'ai pas comique des chiens
j'ai connu des ports aussi les ports de
plaisance les ports de plaisance les
ports avec des grosses péniche des
bittes d'amarrage et des ports qua non
mais sérieux franchement c'est difficile
moi personnellement j'ai eu difficile à
les satisfaire ou alors c'était si
c'était pas le poid fectivement c'était
la tenue vestimentaire qui leur
convenait pas et la dernière fois que
j'étais avec un ami qui m'a dit chéri ce
soir on sort fait un effort
fais-toi belle traduction au repos tu es
moche
donc ce soir là j'ai fait un effort j'ai
vu une petite jupe des petits escarpins
un petit décolleté affriolant même si
bon chez moi on a bien compris que pas
de quoi s'affoler
je suis arrivé tout content comme ça il
m'a dit tu vas sortir comme ça on dirait
[__] tu dis ok tu vois je serais même
changé je dirais de mettre un truc
tranquille j'ai mis un jogging baskets
il fut revenu il m'a dit toi tu risques
comme ça on dirait mon cousin hamid
ok tu vois je te dis on va faire simple
efficace j'ai enfilé de là bas je suis
revenu matt giteau sortir comme ça en
piratant kameda si tu sais quoi
je suis retourné j'ai trouvé tout ce qui
touche tout ce qui me passait sous la
main une chemise en velours un soutien
gorge par dessus à chaud du real madrid
et bas résille chaussettes adidas des
babouches
je revenais m'a dit ça sera dur comme ça
on dirait ma tante amis d'aqui essayer
de faire un put
je suis dit tu sais quoi chérie je sors
pas ce soir je reste à la maison
je regarde la télévision je suis resté
chez moi j'ai allumé la télé devinez ce
que c'était les rênes du shopping tout
le monde connaît oui bon rien qui me
laisse pas ces dommages là la partie qui
vacille va pas trop vous intéresser les
rênes du shopping chez christina
cristina cordula ya qu elle manie faille
qu'il ya que l c'est la reine les autres
c'était mal et on est bien d'accord t'as
vu cette tête d'un coma elle parle aux
gens elle te détruit des personnalités
elle te sape des morales mais avec son
grand sourire elle son petit accent
brésilien sympathie ma chérie cette
fois-là y avait une petite participantes
elles étaient comment vous dire elle
était comme au niveau de mes cuisses
mais partout on cale était un peu
globalement ce fric
christina l'a vu à le faire aïe aïe aïe
mon chéri samba de tous deux parlent des
files par subban tao que ce prix pourra
h
tin oo ça veut dire teboul tu roules à
ma chérie leblanc sur toi ça va pas sa
tasse en fait pas un pli mais il ya du
volume en bas ya du volume
la série sera pas du tout ça fait mon
fils à la vanille 1
j'adore avec le café de temps à autre un
pas tous les jours sinon je deviens
comme toi or ma chère et ne t'inquiète
pas on a tout prévu
bourse aux disques que cela forme un
jardinier une équipe au top qui va faire
du boudin que tu es une rame
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ben viens cas où tu as je t'en prie les
interviews la table d'intervilles massée
petit déplacement valait le coup non
franchement super sa part vous êtes au
top je regrette pas d'avoir fait quatre
heures de route
[Applaudissements]
t'as pas l'air convaincu je sais c'était
bien politiques que tu avais fait la
comaga gênant quand vous êtes au top
j'ai bien fait prendre le rer a c'est
quoi ton écrite et alors ben moi je joue
deviner ou en belgique
donc voilà je fais partie d'un collectif
qui s'appelle le collectif y ont rien
il ya plein d'humoristes super sympa
donc je vous invite à découvrir la page
facebook you rire comme ça s'entend
thierry et voilà donc je fais des scènes
j'en ai une
si vendredi j'en ai encore une samedi
voilà nous rires collectifs kaoutar et
veyran à bruxelles aussi on peut te voir
à bruxelles bas tout est sur la page du
collectif 1 d'accord 38e et bien écoutez
on peut encore le dire kaoutar s'il vous
plaît merci
[Applaudissements]
ça fait plaisir d'être itw ça va mieux
epic monté de 1,8 d'un public oui t'as
vu le rigolo la longue ce n'est pas fini
en plus des noms mais c'est même pas
fini c'est fini mais nous mettons
d'accord c'est bientôt la fin mais non
des moindres alors alors on vous disait
à quoi on aime bien vous proposer de la
nouveauté aussi des jeunes que vous ne
connaissez pas forcément
alors aujourd'hui on a amené un avec
nous on l'a mené en larmes et de paris 1
mai vient de partout à l'ehess ordinaire
elle est maligne elle est drôle
allez allez découvrir
allez là
[Musique]
ça va ça se passe bien je suis ravi
d'être avec vous ce soir moi c'est many
j'ai annoncé à mes amis récemment que je
faisais du stand-up
ce n'était pas une bonne idée avec
certains j'ai eu le sentiment de faire
un réel coming out
tout le monde sait ce que c'est qu'un
coming out un coming out c'est quand tu
révèles à tout le monde quelque chose
qui regardent que toi j'ai le sentiment
de faire un coming out le coming out
c'est souvent pour dire des choses très
personnelles c'est surtout pour révéler
son orientation sexuelle
mais c'est aussi utilisé dans d'autres
contextes et un terme qu'on utilise
aussi par exemple si tu es musulman et
que tu dis aux membres de la communauté
que tu manges pas que de la viande halal
coming out si tu es juif c'était juive
par exemple et que tu dis que tu as
envie de faire un don coming out site
est chrétien et tu dis qu'en 2019 tulle
et encore coming out
voilà alors le coming out généralement
on a beaucoup d'appréhension beaucoup
d'appréhension on a peur de perdre des
gens qu'on aime
avant de le dire moi j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi avant de dire que je voulais
faire du stand up
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi ensuite j'ai
analysé les gens que j'avais peur de
perdre et je me suis dit qu'au final ce
n'était pas si grave si je les perdais
eux que je pouvais faire mieux dans la
vie après j'ai eu d'autres réactions
j'ai des amis qui ont changé d'attitude
ils sont devenus très lourd à faire des
blagues tout le temps aussi lourd que
tous ces gens savaient qu'on croise avec
un bouquet de fleurs dans la rue que
vous disent oh mais fallait pas comme si
on avait l'intention de leur offrir les
faire vous connaissez ces gens là donc
ils sont devenus très lourd mais aussi
très généreux parce que pour le coup ils
font des blagues lourdes et aime les
offres tiens c'est cadeau tu peux
l'utiliser si tu celle là mais ni
réserve en gt avec un pote on était en
train de déjeuner au restaurant et il se
lève son genou claque
il me dit ah je crois que je viens de
faire un strabisme du genou
ah ah et il me l'a offerte
moi j'aurais préféré qu'il ferme sa
gueule et qui me paye le déjeuner bon
moi je me pose beaucoup de questions
existentielles je suis ce genre de
personne je me pose des questions
existentielles surtout sur n'importe
quoi et est en fait je lis beaucoup le
développement personnel pour savoir un
peu comment avancer dans la vie en
développement personnel on te dit faut
que tu aies des objectifs bien définis
et en fonction de ses objectifs
tu fais un plan d'action moi dans mon
plan d'action il y à une playlist une
playlist motivante inspirante
sauf que j'avais pas prévu djadja
d'aller nakamura
j'avais pas prévu ce sont la première
fois que j'ai entendu ce sont mon
cerveau conscient a réfuté il a dit non
sauf que mon inconscient était déjà en
train de chorégraphier djadja j'ai dû
l'intégrer de manière non consentie je
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte de
la puissance de ce sont mesdames et
messieurs récemment j'étais à new york
dans un roof top grosse soirée à
manhattan vous voyez l'ambiance madame
un peu ou pas et est donc il y avait
cette chanson de beyoncé très connus
savez signe que la vidéo ryan a aidé un
donc j'aimerais si vous connaissez le
clip mais bien c est là avec deux
danseuses et elle des boîtes de manière
énergétique le coup les mains les anges
tous les vocalises explosivo a eu un été
des gens en boîte de nuit qui est en
train de danser à 6 ils ont pas jugé
nécessaire d'honorer l'effort de bien
c'est non par contre juste après le dj
balance geagea et là je vois des corps
se déployer à new york pour danser sur
dja dja au aya nakamura dans son clip
elle a deux copines à elle elle marche
au jihad jane ya pas moyen djadja
c'était la première fois que j'entendais
des américains faire du yaourt sur un
son en français aussi
y'a pas manie djadja nom très très
puissant ce sens je me pose beaucoup de
questions existentielles avec le
développement personnel ça me permet de
me connaître je me rends compte que j'ai
un réel problème est que l'engagement
quand il le mouvement des gilet jaune en
france moi j'étais au mexique à mexico
city et j'étais en train de déguster
différentes variétés de tacos avec mes
amis mexicains et et les mexicains dit
emenike bassan une frontière tepa
semblent elles sont agressives il
colorie l'épaisse raonnaise moi j'étais
là mais c'est quoi ce délire de gilet
jaune
peut-être que je mens forme sur ce qui
se passe dans mon pays il faut peut-être
que je m'engage un peu du coup j'ai été
sur la toile j'étais regardez un peu les
titres les titres des journaux
quand j'ai vu les gilet jaune
france divisée et gilet jaune la france
d oublier il ya un article qui a attiré
mon attention parce que le titre était
un peu différent c'est en français et je
sentais que ça venait pas de france le
titre était le suivant le roi est nu et
je me suis dit j'ai envie de dire cet
article qui vient d'afrique
c'est donc je vous imaginez qu est ce
qui s'est passé ce jour là dans la rédac
en afrique lorsque le rédac'chef il est
avec son équipe n'était pas inspiré
stella en france des gens qui revend tic
va inspirer et je pense que ce jour là
il ya un journaliste il arrivé un peu en
retard dans les bureaux il y avait des
portes battantes il a poussé les portes
battantes comme ça et tout le monde la
regarde elle a dit le loi est nu l ont
fait et s'est dit mais j'ai pas rédigé
l'article en fait donc il est parti vers
son bureau il s'est assis devant son
clavier son ordinateur
il a commencé à rédiger et toute
l'équipe était derrière vous donner de
leçon
ac de trion soulier président hu et mais
où l autorité et donc ça a été
chorégraphié j'ai pas vu la chorégraphie
je peux pas vous la faire mais c'était
plus un règlement de compte qu'un
article vous l'aurez compris moi je
pense que cet épisode de la colonisation
il est pas tout à fait passé je pense
que c'est un peu restée en travers de la
gorge la colonisation les épisodes
précédents également et je pense que
c'est en partie lié aussi au au discours
que les présidents français on fait
quand ça concerne l afrique a toujours
été une petite once de mépris le même
mépris que les gens qui sont en couple
honte à l'égard des gens célibataires
vous voyez le genre de mépris ou pas
genre nous on a on a plein de ressources
mais toi pauvre
voyez ce genre de mépris à peu le même
mépris que les gens qui jouent à la
chaise musicale tu sais ce qu'ils ont
trouvé la chaise et regarde celui qui
est encore debout en mode loser mesdames
et messieurs vrai c'était many je vous
remercie
j'ai passé un très bon moment
[Musique]
je connais bien le terme lose lose à la
gratuité t'es dur au début
l faut savoir que moi j'ai envisagé de
faire du stand-up en mode daft punk avec
un casque pour pas qu'on me reconnaisse
pour pas avoir peur des gens c'est une
panique totale
ben oui bêta mais vous avez des vagues
la nuit j'ai oublié le cas c'est gentil
mais ils sont super gentils à l'école
courtois très courtois effectivement pas
hésité drôle alors béni dis moi tu as
une petite actu je croyais que tu es
aussi coach à côté effectivement donc
moi en fait
oui j ai ce qui pouvait arrêter de
mentir au peuple et donc moi en fait
la loose c'est mon truc
et en fait je me suis dit plutôt que
d'être coach en développement personnel
je vais coacher les gens pour ruiner
leur vie donc je suis coach en
destruction personnel c'est un concept
que j'ai inventé mais dans lequel ge
excellent et je vous invite à découvrir
les vidéos avec toutes les astuces sur
mon facebook
many many voilà n'hésitez pas à faire
des commentaires a promis m est animée
et aimer aimer aimer y voilà c'est ici
et là mais je viens d construit en est
ravi et je crois que tu vas participer
aussi à plusieurs scènes ouvertes
absolument quand j'avais moins peur du
public je parle bien sûr qu'un titre
aujourd'hui
non mais je vais faire des zones à la gt
pas non plus il ya quelqu'un qui te file
que tu vois moi c'était le bal des
mamies mon ami tu sais qu'il ya quatre
caméras qui sont autour de nous ouais
c'est pourquoi tu filmes parce que ces
deux arabes c'est mes amis c'est ça leur
coûte moins cher ouais je comprends pas
douze sorties qui est bref mais dis donc
on ne te retrouver sur des scènes
ouvertes
je suis sûr qu'on retrouvera bientôt à
l'olympia ouais ouais ça c'est c'est
bien c'est ouais c'est là bas où le mois
prochain
c'est en est bien sûr on consulte à ta
page facebook vous pouvez encore appelé
merci à céline la pagaie alors là mais
c'est de très près cette soirée gens
savaient vraiment ravi un papy tout de
suite en gb coûte finalement oui c'est
pas mal oui c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
et aulas on a eu on a eu la crème on a
eu le cateau et c'est vrai que parfois
une cerise sur la gâteau c'est mal me
paraît oui il paraît alors faut
peut-être devant d'alexis va peut-être
nous trouver le jambon à la cerise on va
arrêter de demander la recette alexis on
s'est dit une petite cerise sur le
gâteau ce serait peut-être pas mal oui
oui et du coup je me suis dit mon baby
foot remonter le moral peut-être
surprise
petite cerise il vient d'ici il est très
drôle
vous pouvez le voir à la télé sur scène
et surtout pouvez le voir ici ce soir
c'est
[Musique]
oh
comment
je suis
[Musique]
ce pas
koné
mais là
une folle
[Musique]
voilà flash lequel il a allumé son
téléphone toute la soirée
issa doumbia te vois au prix ce ton
sourire des surprises en plus il ça on a
on a on a au delà de ça on a un merci
bonsoir tout le monde ça à tout le monde
et qui font vraiment franchement je
trouve ça bien merci
et à chaque fois en fait après toi tu
vas pleurer quand je dire des trucs mais
bon à chaque fois que tu ne l'as pas
basse basse bosse on a eu la course le
féminisme tout à l'heure mais son atout
obtenu tu viens de finir de travailler
chez darty je t'aime passer des fringues
assez bon merci papa fou un pardon
excusez moi je vous ai coupé non ça va
non je voulais dire juste un truc
en fait je me suis aperçu que j'avais
déjà joué dans cette salle c'est bernard
est un spectacle avec papy et ouais
c'est vrai et ma joie ici et tu étais
mon beau père
exactement enfin on va pas raconter mais
mais mais mais bon c'est vrai que c'est
un souvenir
on en a plein qui ça parce que forcément
il vient de vient de la maison
deviennent des kits théâtre et on se
connaît depuis longtemps et il y avait
un spectacle qui s'appelait face à face
et qu'on a joué ici est effectivement
dans ce personnage enfin j'étais marié à
sa fille et je me rappelle très bien en
bas dans la salle de répète m'ont donné
on avait un indu où je me retrouve avec
mon beau-père et on s'est dit
vian on sait faire ça on va improviser
quelque chose et j'avoue que ça a été un
moment d'anthologie tous les deuxièmes
franchement c'était bon c'était pas mal
mais je pense que les gens s'en foutent
un peu de ça ah bon ben non justement en
fait on voulait est invité pour parler
tous ensemble a déjà relevé l'âge tu as
ta place est plus que n'importe qui ici
au nom si tous leurs points ce soir
france non mais qu'est ce que voit que
ça fait vraiment sens et on s'est dit
que ce soir ce serait peut-être le
moment aussi si vous avez des questions
à pourrissent abbas et moment il est là
il est sous vos yeux ébahis si ça ne te
dérange pas pas du tout coincé et
surtout bah si tu pouvais nous raconter
un peu ce qui t'arrive moi c'est
pourquoi par exemple bien mathieu qui a
joué et tout à l'heure et ça m'a
beaucoup touché limite ému parce que
c'était mon élève d'un pro donc du coup
quand je le vois sur scène et qui qui
s'est toujours bien se tenir et qui sait
bien gigoter sur scène mais bon il ya
encore du travail on va en parler tout à
l'heure
mais je trouve ça déjà tellement
courageux vous savez pas comment c'est
traumatisant de monter sur scène parce
que monter sur scène tout seul face à un
public qui attend de rire c'est toujours
compliqué donc du coup juste de venir et
de comment non ça c'est quand même un
public courtois et courtoise cette
blague faut que tu arrêtes papé oui mais
moi je sais qu'une blague
oui je te connais tu vas y est allé
jusqu'au bout voilà mais un moment ils
sont en voiture après n'ont été pas mal
quand même courtois qu'antoine à ses
élans courtois
ouais c'est quand même bien merci c'est
gentil je continue à me la faire tout
seul la base continue et celle de la
faire sur la place du marché ici copains
faut pas parler du marché très bien
alors ils ont qu un dock se disait que
c'était très courageux de monter sur
scène
est ce qu'il est ce qu'il ya déjà des
gens en salles qui sont déjà montés sur
scène ici ou pas du tout ou qui ont
envie de monter sur scène
oui la charmante jeune fille d'à part
qu'ils quittent fille petit peu lever la
main tu as le droit tu ne seras pas
juger pensent que c'est facile de monter
sur scène bien ce que disent ben vas-y
vient ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant faut venir laisse les
souvenirs communs chaussettes maintenant
aussi mais il faut que tes parents paie
des impôts
allez viens de le dire pour leur gardien
bien profond voilà bien les citoyens
bravo les parents et tu vois déjà c'est
pas facile de monter sur le tabouret et
quand tu viens tu as un pull un manteau
tient à temps je te place mon micro
comment tu t'appelles tu es la gare
théodore tu as quel âge
si vingt six ans non mais attendez
attention aucune valeur tout à l'heure
j'ai dit mon prénom personne n'a
applaudi ok donc ce que j'aime c'est que
les enfants ils ont pas de chiffres il y
va il s'en fout et à vue il ya plein
d'adultes ici ton micro il marchera 4
pins je veux parler de dents vas-y par
allot tu t'entends est-ce que je n'ai
pas chez les ch qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez allumer la lumière est ce que
vous pouvez allumer la salle s'il vous
plaît si c'est possible ou pas non voilà
tu as vu tous les gens qu'il ya dans la
salle mais les creux beaucoup comme
maintenant il est en train de les
compter ses petits jobs ne fait pas cet
exercice t'as vu ça fait beaucoup quand
même
et tu vois c'est pareil côté quand tu es
au tableau à l'école tu vois c'est
compliqué de parler devant tout le monde
on est bien d'accord eh ben c'est pour
ça que vous vous êtes les un public
important parce que vous êtes là pour
soutenir les gens et tout ça et du coup
c'est pas facile donc franchement les
applaudir c'est vraiment cool tu sais
toi qu'ils ont des pieds comme ça non
non et non
excuse moi
au niveau de l'hygiène de l'enfant
comment ça se passe faut pas faire sans
c'est vrai qu'un fumer je n'avais pas
senti un ténor
bah merci
c'est pour ça qu'il faut applaudir
terdav s'il vous plaît on pourra lui
acheter du temps cet homme pour enfants
il va falloir te dire la même chose dans
quelques années
oui tu as très bien merci il encore mais
arrête tout ce qu'ils ont fait où ils
n'ont pas de danse moment n'empêche
théodore deck armour dire scène tu l'as
fait avec qui ça ça va hein c'est pas
beau on dirait c'est en train de virer à
l'école des fans mon truc c'est horrible
à 3 du tout non mais en fait je sais pas
moi je suis je suis là pour aussi
partagez donc je peux parler pendant des
heures mais si vous avez des questions
sur alors qu'une question à notre
famille c'est ça allez-y cas voulait
poser une question ils ça une fois deux
fois
à bien ses lames avant d'être elle a
viré le plus qui va rentrer à pied non
mais là des chaussures c'est pas ça
merde j'ai vu ses chaussures d'ailleurs
[__] bonsoir madame bonsoir à tous je
m'appelle josefa je fais leur courtoise
et courtoise je suis là avec plein de
monde donc des enfants et des adultes
demande une association que je préside
assuré l'encours qui se passerait bien
de les voir une association pour les
parents sont les familles monoparentales
d'accord et donc on propose parmi tant
l'action pour les adultes des actions
pour les enfants
oui il a le désir le grand désir serait
de proposer du théâtre pour l'an
prochain pour les enfants parce qu'on
trouve très important justement de
pouvoir leur permettre de se d'esprit
mais également les difficultés qu'ils
rencontrent pardon liés à la séparation
de leurs parents
d'accord
déjà un je vous invite à venir si vous
voulez faire une fois par mois à l'agora
au centre municipal est en cours
d'accord il ya rencontré nos enfants
même pizza dossier beaucoup d'enfants
non il faut passer deux heures avec eux
et puis un peu de théâtre et je vais
savoir qu'est ce qu'être conseil pouvait
leur donner ils ont entre on va dire 14
12 et 14 pour justement pouvoir avoir
confiance en eux et pouvoir aller vers
les gens alors waouh
merci grand moi ce micro et parle
beaucoup trop et trop de trucs à dire
joseph à mais voilà vous retrouver tout
seul c'était facile je vous la corde
je vous la corde mais c'était toute
façon je fais que des blagues comme ce à
quoi ça va c'est pour ça que je mets en
scène des gens parce que moi même ça
sert à rien arrête toi là tu veux aller
loin
tu vas le regretter bah oui alors déjà
félicitations pour votre action
parce que c'est quelque chose c'est bien
et qu'est ce qu'est ce que je peux
conseiller aux enfants moi c'est bizarre
ça c'est pas vraiment le cas j'ai
toujours aimé mes deux parents et j'ai
toujours des relations avec les deux
mais mes parents étaient séparés un
moment et donc du coup je me suis
retrouvé dans une situation où j'étais
un peu perdue donc et je sais pas
comment communiquer avec les gens je ne
savais pas avant la la colère se
transcende les mots se transformer en en
colère en tapage et ce monsieur était
sur mon chemin donc du coup j'ai pris il
a il m'a beaucoup aidé à changer ça et
en fait ça c'est ça c'est ça s'est fait
à travers le théâtre donc ggsu j'ai su
m'exprimer au fur et à mesure donc
dans des personnages ça m'a beaucoup
aidé les personnages le disais c'est pas
moi c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui passe un
message
donc j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup de
théâtre j'en fais encore aujourd'hui la
preuve
et du coup ça va aider vraiment évacuer
plein de choses donc tu as raison josefa
le théâtre était effectivement une belle
solution pour se raconter pour se dire
pour évacuer peut-être des choses
audacieuses rice et pédaler et non mais
c'est vrai et je sais que du coup avec
la maîtresse de maison ici virginie
marson c'est pas pour rien qu'on fait ce
travail là de deux plateaux de jeunes
humoristes qui permettent à des gens
d'ici aussi de venir s'exprimer de
rencontrer des gens comme issa c'est
aussi ça il ya des choses qui vont se
mettre en place et qu'on essaie de
mettre en place
donc on a bien entendu ce que tu nous a
dit et je pense que ce le théâtre est
forcément un bon choix il ça vient de
nous prouver encore là effectivement de
ce qui lui a permis à lui de se raconter
de se dire et le fait si bien
aujourd'hui que il ya plein d'espoir en
fait à se raconter à dernière merci je
sais pas
en tous les cas merci beaucoup
est ce que quelqu'un aura encore une
question pour issa associations dans la
salle qui va le faire leur promo est pas
bon on a bien vu ouais c'est ta pub pour
la lessive la prochaine à londres a dit
tout est permis d eau courante et un
vendredi tout ça ça veut pas non non tu
n'as pas vu à la télé non bâti passe à
la télé je te jeu alors j'ai vu une main
sur le chou oui à papa bonjour bonsoir
acadie et j'aimerais bien faire du
théâtre mais j'sais pas comment
l'exprimer il a vu ton mid est juste à
côté à l'élan cours et il ya de l'impro
dans ton collège ou pas il ya un
camarade dans la casse qui fait du
théâtre et du coup ça t'intéresse pas de
t'inscrire avec lui au début
au début je veux pas te cacher ça va
être dur parce qu'en fait parler devant
des gens c'est toujours compliqué mais à
un moment tu vas y prendre goût et tu va
échanger avec tes autres camarades et ça
va devenir un plaisir et tu va le
transformer donc du coup essaye tu vas
voir ça va te faire beaucoup de bien
parce que tu vas jouer des personnages
et tu vas te dire mon personnage il
arrive à dire ça wahou génial et après
finalement tu vas te dire c'est pas si
compliqué dans la vie de dire les choses
qu'on pense donc du coup essaye de le
faire avec des personnages au début et
après tu vas y arriver dans la vie parce
que ma mère allait déjà fait du théâtre
avec papy a abattu a battu saluera ta
maman comme quoi il ya trop longtemps
que je suis dans le coin
merci
moi c'est les enfants des chenaux elle
est trop vieux trop vieux la merci
inquiet ça fait plaisir a vraiment merci
j'allais lui que j'ai derrière moi
j'avais au mince j'avais question tu
voyais ça peut-être que le public ne
posera pas tu es tu as commencé par
l'impro oui tu parles effectivement
cette incarnation de personnages et de
travail que tu as fait avec mappy
comment tu es passé à l'écriture et
comment tu travailles en écriture
comment tu écris tes textes alors ça ça
va être un jeu racontait un truc que
j'ai peut-être des gens l'ont déjà
entendu mais je vais vous dire comment
j'ai écrit mon spectacle mon spectacle
un jour en fait c'est arthur vous
connaissez arthur qui un jour me propre
me demande en sortie des missions il dit
est ce que tu as un spectacle j'ai dit
oui et me dit ok j'aimerais bien te
rencontrer pour qu'on parle du spectacle
j'ai dit d'accord pas de problème on
était vendredi me dit on se donne rendez
vous mardi guy hoquet donc du coup
j'accepte je le dis jamais me rappellera
toujours il parle comme ça les gens de
la télé mais jamais il vous rappellera
donc du coup lundi à son assistante qui
m'appelle c'est toujours ok pour marc d
oui oui d'accord d'accord
donc je vais au rendez vous mardi et il
me dit alors c'est quoi ton spectacle
est là enfin de l'impro j'improvise un
spectacle sous ses yeux où je lui dis
dans mon spectacle qui assaillent assis
hier sa r6 officie génial ok je veux
bien produire ok super je sors de là
j'appelle papy je dis papy je suis dans
la merde j'ai inventé un spectacle et
j'ai dit que tu étais mon metteur en
scène il faut qu'on bosse
et c'est vrai et ça a fait mon spectacle
moi j'étais tranquille en vacances et
biba dans un mois faut qu'on ait un
spectacle s'il ya que pour tout vous
dire un spectacle il faut le mature et
il faut voilà avec certains ça mais un
an deux ans lui me dit non mais c'est
moi en fait tu es mon metteur en scène
on arthur qui nous produit on n'a rien
mais dans un mois il faut qu'on présente
un spectacle jeu on a passé un mois
d'août sympa et en fait comme ça et
comme comme la personne qui me connaît
le plus en jeu c'était papier donc j'ai
appelé directement papilles on s'est
enfermés pendant un mois dans une salle
et j'avais des personnages que j'avais
déjà joué en impro dans plusieurs
spectacles ou sinon par exemple madame
conakry je l'avais créé avec toi aussi
dans la tête de la tête de l'emploi
donc du coup c'est des personnages que
je suis partie piocher un peu à droite à
gauche et je me suis dit qu'est ce que
j'ai envie de raconter et dans chaque
personnage en fait j'ai mis ce que
j'avais envie de raconter et du coup
j'ai créé mon spectacle comme ça avec
papy je n'ai jamais répéter mon
spectacle mais quand en fait j'avais
cette base de théâtre qui faisait qu' on
ne faisait pas plein de tests de
spectacle je me suis dit ben je vais y
aller comme d'habitude on fait la
première et si ça marche tant mieux si
ça marche pas tant pis et en fait
j'avais jamais répéter avant la première
de la soirée en chantant dont 11 femmes
et hommes est répéteur entier le
spectacle et le soir même juste avant de
commencer jeudi après ça y'a quoi papy
après c'est une fée mais en fait on a
jamais répéter entièrement le spectacle
et l'achever mais pourquoi tu m'as dis
ça mais pourquoi tu m'as dit ça allez
vas-y
ouais bien le spectacle a tourné pendant
trois ans en faisant salle comble donc
très proches mais quand même coup ya
fait te pousse et c'est vrai c'est
génial et du coup ça m'a permis plein de
choses ça m'a permis de partir aussi sur
un truc que je ne connaissais absolument
pas partir sur des choses écrites pas ce
que j'ai fait pendant des années des
spectacles d'improvisation
donc du coup on crée notre personnage
notre histoire sur l'instant t et en
fait ça m'a permis de mélanger les deux
j'ai mélangé un spectacle très écrits à
des moments et à un moment ça des
moments très improvisés donc du coup
c'était avec le public j'arrivais à
créer des histoires
je suis donc le spectacle faisait une
heure et quart ici en septembre et à la
fin il faisait 2 heures un record sur
moi j'étais là tu en entends disant
lecture on a un peu rajouté ou c'est moi
ça va et c'était qu'il en avait rajouté
c'est pourquoi ça tombe à plat s40 est
asiatique question ce que t'es trop
courtois
le oui on vous a repéré avec votre reer
est ce qu'il y aurait encore une
question ou deux dans la salle que vous
voudrez on en profite puisque on a ce
camarade là avec nous là bas je nomme je
viens jeune homme c'est une jeune fille
qui a une casquette des filles jeudi à
casquette balle a pu sa casquette comme
aux yeux de leur père mais il a du bal
ce soir elle a du mal merci beaucoup de
m'avoir confondues issa est ce que tu
dirais que l'humour tu as tu as rendu
meilleur août à sauver deux parce que tu
as vécu j'ai entendu ta question il ya
eu une bonne en même temps et gbagbo qui
a dit ça c'est ta première partie je
crois c'est un futur pas c'est le
monsieur qui filme depuis tout à l'heure
c'est ça répond à la question de la dame
suppose que tu dis ne te cache pas
vilain
ouais
il s'en suit répondre à l'infi à la
jeune fille est ce que ça m'a rendu
meilleur e
je sais pas en tout cas je sais que la
compagnie où j'ai été ma beaucoup
beaucoup formés sur ce métier est en
fait je peux que les remercier parce que
aujourd'hui quand je vais dans une salle
de spectacle en fait je parle avec les
techniciens
je peux très bien mettre en avant
d'autres personnes qui travaillent
autour du spectacle parce que quand j'ai
grandi dans cette compagnie déclic
théâtre
eh ben on m'a appris à ranger mon
matériel on m'a appris à dire bonjour au
revoir aux gens quand on rentre dans une
salle et quand on ressort on m'a appris
à donner de l'importance aussi aux gens
qui travaillent avec nous en les
remerciant fin de spectacle parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d'artistes et je citerai pas
de noms qui pense que tous créé tout
seul
et ils ont tous créé tout seul alors que
c'est pas vrai est vraiment un petit
détail à la con mais si vous rentrez
dans une salle que vous dit bonjour aux
techniciens que vous allez après sur
scène et que vous le remercier à la fin
et ben lui il ira à chaque fois à ce mec
là il est cool et du coup il va
travailler avec vous mais de deux avec
avec le coeur si vous arrivez vous lui
dites pas bonjour y est mal luné il peut
l'éteindre la lumière quand il veut ils
coupent tomic on aggrave
ah c'est ça qui s'est passé tout à fait
j'aurais pu leur dire bonjour vraiment
et cdc des détails à la con mais en fait
on travaille jamais tout seul on n'est
jamais tout seul en spectacle même si
vous voyez quelqu'un tout seul sur scène
il est pas tout seul c'est à dire qu'il
ya des gens qui l'ont formé il ya des
gens qui l'ont aidé à écrire il ya des
gens qui l'ont mis en lumière il ya des
gens qui ont mis un micro cravate ou un
micro pardon casque ou un micro cravate
ou un micro mais il ya quelqu'un qui
prépare en fait cette scène est
quelqu'un qui la nettoyer avant qu'il
ait avant qu'ils montent sur 7 il ya des
gens qui travaillent avec nous et faut
pas l'oublier
donc je pense que ça c'est très très
important merci la technique
tiens à les remercier du coup mais du
coup t'as pas répondu à la question et
ça c'est très triste que ça ma vie si je
vous répondrais ce que ça m'a rendu
meilleur je sais pas je pense que j'ai
une éducation qui fait que je j'ai
toujours respecté les jeunes bonnes
bases je suis meilleur je sais pas
meilleure en jeu peut-être parce que
j'ai moins peur de monter sur scène
meyer dans la vie je ne sais pas ça faut
le demander à mon entourage je c'est
bizarre de répondre à cette question moi
même parce que on dirait que je me vois
je me regarde et je me plaque c'est
bizarre ce mois ci le trouve meilleur
ouais au trivial pursuit par exemple
d'accord alors bienvenue au club j'ai va
me chercher un exempt merci julie tu
crois que tu disais est très très juste
et du coup ça fait une subtile
transition juste pour que au lieu de
faire ça à la fin du spectacle
rapidement c'est effectivement la
dernière de la saison est effectivement
ces plateaux du monde se font pas tout
seul ils se font sous l'impulsion d'une
dynamique d'une équipe dynamique
incroyable juste scoop vous savez
comment ça a remercié les gens je
voudrais le dire juste à tous ceux qui
sont montés sur scène c'était super déjà
vraiment c'est à dire que il faut pas au
début on se casse la gueule parfois
c'est dur et c'est comme ça qu'on se
forment en fait faut pas avoir peur
fausse cassé les dents pour se dire la
rd théodore en fait
[Rires]
à damas il a pas encore danser des dents
de lait cela c'est ça non non c'est
décide en définitive c'est très bien ça
vous donne un départ en fait vous vous
dites j'ai commencé comme ça et je peux
que progresser vous pouvez pas aller à
chaque fois que vous allez remonter sur
scène vous pouvez pas aller en dessous
de ce que vous avez fait la dernière
fois proche d aller toujours de l'avant
continuer si vous voulez prenez des
auteurs des gens qui sont autour de vous
pour écrire pour vous aider à structurer
les choses mais lâchez pas c'est pas
genre j'ai fait cette scène c'était dur
c'est pas mon truc
si c'est vraiment là eh ben vous y ait
un vrai voilà merci
du coup ma transition est toute pourrie
maintenant c'est pato se sont organisés
sous la plus jeune je voulais dire un
truc et ben voila je joue encore
remercie toute l'équipe du théâtre du
prisme est particulièrement chi chi wah
sens bien j'ai des garçons alexandra car
tout le monde
td 78e c'est qu'il nous a accompagnés
des faits et les fils theodor ils sont
plus en fils
à cet effet dit ça c'était avant
l'arrivée 70 excusez moi par mail fils
ils se sont ouverts demain c'était les
soixante dix huit pardon excusez moi
sans fil sans fil est telle et 78 tous
fêter ce club et on est vraiment heureux
que l'humour
voilà soit en résidence ici ça
continuera l'année prochaine et
ou pas on vient de nous apprendre que
notre salaire a été multiplié par dix
papilles alors ça continuait ce même
pris les commandes dès samedi on va on
va peut-être clôturer cette manière
alors à temps parce que quand même
ballet youtube je crois qu'il faut quand
même qu'on si on est là c'est pas pour
rien il ya vraiment quelqu'un c'est tout
ça moi je tiens mon chapeau quand même à
virginie ouais ouais
et la patronne la main à la pâte en de
cette maison qui nous invite
merci bien gibier d'avoir pensé à nous
en faire ça et bravo bravo au travail
que tu fais au quotidien pour elle c'est
la maison et ça va on bricole nous
qu'est ce qui se passe et j'ai retrouvé
chez quoi
la fille de pierre richard mais
messieurs bonsoir et merci
on pourrait vous applaudir vous deux
julie chaise papy papilles et si on
appelait le comédien oui comédienne
parle et ben alors
et oui ça alors de papy dont tu te mets
de l'autre conjoint le il sera
aujourd'hui et on t'appellera
discrètement pour le dernier salue ce
soir mesdames et messieurs nous avions
des artistes rien pour vous c'est
l'heure d'aller mais la musique qu'ighil
ok
[Musique]
hu
je ne pars pas
non
à l'essai
[Musique]
mais
habillé voir où ça se voit on
[Musique]
et
soit examinée
nous subissons
paris
coucou
[Musique]
sur le coup le 20 mai aps la saison
prochaine ovo reverse l'histoire
m
restée courtoise
et vous tous les pôles soir
[Musique]
vidéo